Німці вважаються однією з найбільш ощадливих націй у світі.
Середньостатистичний бюргер воліє жити економно
і багато чого відкладає "на потім". До цього привчають з дитинства.
Після сплати податків у пересічного німця
в середньому залишається на руках близько 2000 євро.
Цією сумою намагаються розпоряджатися
дуже розумно, ретельно плануючи бюджет.
У першу чергу зароблені гроші витрачаються
на оплату оренди житла або погашення кредиту на нерухомість.
Це може становити аж половину доходів.
Потім - сплата комунальних послуг і страховок.
На їжу німці витрачають лише близько 9% своїх доходів.
Для порівняння: французи, італійці та іспанці
витрачають на харчування значно більше -
від 13 до 15% своїх доходів.
А ще німці люблять економити на воді.
У цьому вони переплюнули всі європейські країни.
За останні два десятиліття споживання води
на душу населення в Німеччині постійно знижується.
Якщо на початку 1990-х років одне домашнє господарство
споживало близько 150 літрів води щодня, то
сьогодні - на 20 літрів менше. В Іспанії, приміром,
води витрачають удвічі більше.
Купуючи пральну або посудомийну машину,
німець звертає увагу передусім на її економність.
У кожній квартирі є лічильники витрат холодної та гарячої води.
І коли німці, приміром, чистять зуби, то вимикають
воду у крані, бо це вважається марнотратством.
Так само в душі, коли намилюються.
Або миючи посуд, часто роблять це не під протічною водою,
а набирають раковину спершу для миття з миючою рідиною,
а потім - для споліскування.
Стиль "економ" німці полюбляють і в одязі, меблях та прикрасах.
Речі від модних брендів не є для них предметами першої необхідності.
Якщо вони їх і купують, то переважно дочікуються розпродажу.
Меблі полюбляють купувати у шведського дискаунтера ІКЕА,
а надмір прикрас і активна демонстрація розкоші
нерідко сприймаються як моветон.
А от що стосується автомобіля, то тут німці
себе особливо не обмежують. На утриманні
свого залізного коня більшість бюргерів не економить.
Регулярно відвідують станції технічного обслуговування та мийки машин
і навіть колеса воліють міняти не самі, а радше
довіряють своє авто автомеханікам.
Так само не економлять німці на відпустці.
Переважна більшість - 59% - із задоволенням
інвестують гроші в якісний відпочинок на курортах
або в захоплюючі тури, під час яких можна
дізнатися багато нового, познайомитися
з культурою і традиціями іншої країни. При цьому
вони активно подорожують і Німеччиною -
далеко не найдешевшою в туристичному плані країною.
У масштабах усієї країни особливо люблять економити
жителі Нижньої Саксонії та Бремена.
А найменше людей, які відкладають
гроші "на чорний день", - у Гамбурзі та Берліні.
За даними соцопитувань, кожен другий німець
щомісяця відкладає певну суму. Причому
для накопичення грошей перевага віддається
класичній ощадкнижці, хоча відсоткові ставки
за вкладами, які нині пропонують європейські банки,
дуже низькі. Така вже специфіка національного менталітету -
менше ризику. Надійність і гнучкість вкладень
значно важливіша для німця, ніж їх прибутковість.
У середньому житель Німеччини намагається
відкладати не менше 10% від своїх доходів.